turning now to the war in ukraine the
government says russia has launched a
massive new offensive in the eastern
part of the country the regional
governor of harkiv says more than a
dozen people there were injured by a
barrage of russian rockets russian
occupied territory is now concentrated
in the east and the south but they do
not have control of the key cities of
harkev or mariupo chris livesay reports
on this new phase of the war
russian troops have begun the battle for
donbass says ukrainian president
volodomir zielinski
setting the stage for major clashes of
tanks and heavy artillery unlike
anything we've seen since world war ii
ukraine says it's a massive buildup in
the eastern region of ongoing clashes
none more infamous than marijual
after weeks of resistance now on the
brink of doom russia has told its last
die-hard defenders holed up in this
steel mill surrender or die but they
refuse to give up
looking for hope in cities like
chernohee north of key it too was
besieged for weeks
but against all odds it was a triumph
for ukraine
last month shooting down this russian
bomber it crashed into this home killing
the owner but shockingly no more its
payload failing to explode when it
landed on nikolai's doorstep so this is
your house right over here
so it's just a matter of feet that's
unbelievable he's so lucky
others were not so fortunate some 50
people were killed in this apartment
building one of the deadliest single
strikes of the war
all of a sudden i was covered in
shattered glass says larissa she takes
me into her bunker where these women
have been hiding for more than a month
at one point they could barely fit here
200 people were in here
now we have lights she says but for a
long time all we had were candles are
you afraid that they're going to come
back why not the war goes on she says
we're begging your country for more
weapons we don't know what's waiting for
us out there
and this morning the same could be said
anywhere in ukraine moscow says it
struck more than 1200 targets overnight
here in kiev the air raid sirens have
been sounding with vladimir putin out to
prove that even if his invasion is now
concentrated on the east nowhere in
ukraine is safe gail
that's hard to hear thank you very much
chris livesay reporting from ukraine